voilà
[Musique]
c'est la bombe toutes les sensations
tout ce que j'ai retenu en moi pendant
des années là je les exprime pour la
première fois en solo c'est ma première
expérience de danse en individuel donc
ça va exploser je sais pour moi en
émotions et j'espère que vous allez la
recevoir cette bombe avec beaucoup
d'amour que je veux vous donner
[Musique]
la roma
de l'homme
la vente ou renault
on arrive comme ça dans la danse en
étant déjà au départ dans la musique et
suit un voyage à cuba lors de ma
réussite au bac j'ai eu le coup de
foudre en allant voir un orchestre à la
casa della musica à cuba et voilà à
partir de ce moment j'ai compris que la
danse était fait pour moi umicore vibrer
et panne n'est pas ok c'est la salsa oui
parce qu'elle a des couleurs chaudes
tout le corps s'exprime toute sa
féminité son expression je me retrouve
totalement
[Musique]
tous